[MUSIC PLAYING]
MOHAN KRISHNAN: Hello!
Good morning, ladies
and gentlemen.
My name is Mohan Krishnan.
And I'm the CTO at BBM.
Today, I want to
share with you guys
a story about how we
migrated the BBM users--
and this is what was originally
known as the BlackBerry
Messenger-- from our Canadian
data center, on-prem,
to Google Cloud.
Before starting though,
I'd like to ask maybe
you guys a couple of questions.
Firstly, how many of you all
are considering doing migration
from on-prem to the cloud
in maybe the next six
to nine months?
Show of hands?
OK, great.
So hopefully this content
is relevant for you all.
The next question, how many
of you all know what BBM is?
OK, keep your hands up.
How many of you all
know that BBM is today
available on Android and iOS
and continuously being improved?
Great!
So you guys know our story.
That's awesome.
Thank you very much.
So let's start.
What I'd like to start with
is a bit of background,
because I get lots of questions
as to what's going on with BBM?
What's happening?
So this is just to
set things up a bit.
I work for a company
called Emtek.
Emtek is Indonesia's
largest media conglomerate.
We own TV stations, both paid
and free-to-air national TV
stations.
We own production houses and
been in the media business
for about 5 to 10 years.
In about the last
two to three years,
we've also been going
online, primarily, again,
taking our content from
traditional media to online.
So we run, today, Indonesia's
largest online news portals,
similar to like Conde
Nast but for the internet.
We also run Indonesia's
second largest video platform.
We're only second to YouTube.
Today, our content
and our services
touch over 50 to 60 million
monthly active users
in Indonesia.
As part of that
strategy, of growing
that side of the
business, we decided
that, besides just being
a content producer,
we also wanted to be a platform,
a platform for people to come
and consume our content.
To that goal, we found
that in Indonesia there's
still a large
amount of BBM users
compared to the
rest of the world.
And we then engaged with
BlackBerry to wholly license--
so we've acquired a
license from BlackBerry--
for BBM for the
consumer business.
So today, since 2016, when
the agreement was signed,
we build, develop,
and distribute
BBM for the consumer market.
A key part of achieving
our goals around that
was migrating BBM.
And I'm going to get into the
specifics around that in a bit.
But I'd like to share how
large, from a human standpoint,
this project was.
It spanned about two years.
We officially only
finished in June 2018.
It involved anywhere
between 40 to 60 engineers,
spanned across
12-hour time zones,
across three
different countries,
Canada, Singapore, and Jakarta.
The next thing I want
to share with you guys,
before we get to the
specifics, is that this is not
your father's BBM anymore.
Many people still think that
BBM is only available on BBOS
and BB10 devices.
This is BBM for Android and
iOS, modern operating systems.
Apart from that,
this is also a BBM
that is on par with
your modern Facebook
Messengers and WhatsApp.
This includes things like
video and voice calling,
large groups, availability on
multiple platforms including
desktop.
And more importantly,
what we've been focused on
and why we made
this transition is
we're building features
for our market.
How many of you all are
familiar with WeChat?
So OK, WeChat, you
guys know that story.
It's huge in China.
And the reason why
it's huge, also,
is because it's a messenger
that's focused for that market.
That's exactly what we're doing.
We're trying to make BBM
the WeChat of Indonesia.
To that goal, we've been
building features like wallets.
So today, if you
use BBM Indonesia,
you can send money
to each other.
You can make transactions.
You can buy things
like internet pop ups
or pay your phone bills.
Apart from that, we've
also been integrating BBM
into the local phone systems.
In the next two months,
we will be rolling out
a feature where you can
make calls and receive
calls via a number that
is assigned to your BBM.
So when you register
for BBM in Indonesia,
you get a local phone number.
And you can use it.
This is extremely
relevant for the market
that we operate
where there are still
many users, who
are in rural areas,
with very poor
data connectivity.
They can still keep in
touch by piggybacking
on the PSTN network to
contact their friends
and family on BBM.
So in a nutshell, what
was the transition?
So it involved moving the
BBM infrastructure footprint
from Canada all the way to
GCP in the Asian region.
And why did we do this?
Well, first and foremost,
as you guys probably know,
the global user base
for BBM has reduced.
But there's still a
sizable user base in Asia,
primarily in Indonesia, in
Africa, and in the Middle East.
We wanted to bring
the BBM services
closer to where our users are.
This will improve latency.
It would also improve
network reliability.
That was the first goal.
But a second major driving
goal was replatforming
BBM on cloud
infrastructure that'll
allow us to build
the type of features,
that I was talking
about earlier,
in a fast and effective manner.
That was a huge goal.
Lastly, it's important
to keep in mind
that, during the entire 1 and
1/2 years that we were doing
this transition, we still
had billions of messages
and tens of millions of
users using the platform
without any problem.
We were migrating them,
in the background,
without them realizing, and
not impacting their service.
Also, during these 18
months, we continued
to push out new and exciting
features for our user base.
So what was it that we migrated?
I know there are
some ex BlackBerry
people in the audience today.
So these guys are
probably familiar with it.
But BBM was not a simple
application to migrate.
It consisted of over
20 major components.
Each of these components
had multiple subcomponents.
You look at it and
you might go, wow.
It looks like a
microservices architecture.
From our end, I think it was
an accidental microservice
architecture.
It was an amalgamation of
different components, built
over a 10 to 3 year time
line, from different teams,
using different
technologies and frameworks
that were available
at that point.
That added a lot of complexity.
We had everything from JBoss,
different version of Spring,
custom Java frameworks
that we had to rationalize
and plan how we were going
to deploy and run in GCP.
Apart from that, it was
a sizable infrastructure
footprint, over 14,000 VMs,
on physical machines running
in BlackBerry's data centers
in Canada, NetApp appliances,
Fusion-io, fiber-based
storage, a large data
analytics and Hadoop
clusters, and also
an assortment of databases.
We had to migrate a
600 node Cassandra
cluster, multiple mySQL and
Postgres databases, as well.
So it was a large piece
of infrastructure to move.
This diagram here is
mostly for shock factor.
Don't look at it too hard.
But this is an attempt
at trying to map out
all the different
components that made up
BBM and their interconnection.
As you can see,
the summary is it
wasn't a simple system,
neatly compartmentalized
into logical components.
That, it was not.
So how did we do the migration?
What did it involve?
There were three
major parts or tasks
that we had to go through.
Firstly, was the preparation.
And I'll talk about
that in a bit.
Secondly, we mapped out
the different services
that were running and how they
would end up running in GCP.
And lastly was the
actual traffic cutover.
And I'll go through
that one by one.
What we were trying to
answer in preparation was
what is there to move and
where do we move it to?
The reason why we had this
question, of what is that move,
was, keep in mind,
that the team that
was going to do this
migration, for the most part,
did not build and did
not operate the service.
They didn't have any idea
as to what was running.
So we had to go
through a process
of trying to
inventory the service
and understand what
was there first.
From an inventory standpoint,
there were two major aspects.
Firstly, was just mapping
out the individual services.
Where is the source
code for this service?
How do you build it?
What are the Jenkins pipelines?
What are the dependencies?
What are the configurations
that we need to pull in?
Each component had
anywhere between 400 to 500
different configurations.
At times, there
were configurations
where people didn't understand.
It's just been that
way for multiple years.
And we had to do a lot
of so-called archeology
to try to figure out and
put the pieces together.
And the second part
of the inventory
was from an
operations standpoint.
How did these services run
in their current on-prem
infrastructure?
What were the type
of service that were
required to run these services?
What were the type of
metrics and alerting
that was used to make sure that
these services were healthy?
What type of log output
did they produce?
Which parts of the
log were relevant
from an operational standpoint?
And lastly, even
bandwidth utilization,
because we were
moving to a model
where egress bandwidth
was going to be needed,
as opposed to a
typical on-prem setup,
where you buy the bulk,
top, peak bandwidth
throughput that you need.
So we had to map that
out and figure it out.
What worked really well for
us, from a service standpoint
of trying to figure out
how the service ran,
is that we documented
everything in code.
We didn't just
write it all down.
We actually had our
developers work-out,
write Ansible playbooks
to get this all set up.
And they made sure that
the services at least
stood up within a Vagrant box.
That gave us the assuredness
that this information
was documented.
From an operation
standpoint, what we did was
we created this
giant spreadsheet
as you can see here.
Again, don't look
at it too hard.
But essentially, it mapped
out all different aspects
of the service and how
it ran in production.
The next step was
actually deciding
where we were going to go.
It wasn't a slam dunk that
we were moving to GCP.
We actually ran POCs with
three different cloud vendors.
I'm sure Tim and some of the
guys from Google in the crowd
still remember this.
We ran two to four week POCs
on site with BlackBerry,
where what we did was
we tried to put one,
two key services into the
cloud and then actually load
test it in there,
see how it worked.
This gave us two things.
Firstly, it helped
us further understand
these individual services,
because we were also still
figuring it out.
And secondly, it gave
us a lot more clarity
as to how the
services were running
within the individual
cloud providers.
In the end, we
did an evaluation.
We evaluated on
three major criteria,
the technical capabilities of
the cloud provider, its partner
support, and costs.
And it goes without
saying, I'm here at Next,
and GCP was the winner.
And we've been happy
with that decision.
We've been happy
with the decision.
It's really worked out for us.
From a partner
standpoint, as well,
we worked with some
really great partners,
like Pythian and CloudCover,
who are also in the room here
today.
And that really got
us over the line.
The table on the right,
here, shows some--
like, in a condensed form--
the different aspects
of the comparison.
There were a lot more details.
I can get into specifics,
if you guys want,
but it was a long process.
By the time we were
done with this phase,
inventorying the system and
picking the cloud vendor,
we were four months into
this project already.
So now that we know
what we want to migrate,
we know where we're
going to migrate to,
the next step was to
really figure out,
how are we going to have these
components run in the cloud?
And the first
question-- and I've
seen this question being
repeated through conversations
that I've had with
other people who
have gone through migration.
And I'm sure some of you guys,
who are considering migration
now, are having this
exact question--
is do we just lift
and shift the services
as is or do we use this as an
opportunity to re-engineer it,
replatform it on something new?
Now intuitively, lifting
and shifting makes sense.
You minimize risk.
You're already making
this major change.
Why change the application
at the same time?
Why increase the complexity?
But the challenge with
services that were originally
built for on-prem
infrastructure, I believe,
is that sometimes there
are certain aspects
or certain operational
aspects of those services
that rely on very specific
on-prem characteristics.
Trying to replicate these
on-prem characteristics
in the cloud end up adding
risk to your project.
So I don't think
it's a done deal.
I don't think
anybody, who's making
a large migration, a
complex enough migration,
is ever going to have purely a
lift and shift or a replatform,
re-engineer.
It's going to be a
spectrum, a hybrid approach.
And for us, that's
exactly what happened.
There were certain
characteristics of components
that, when we saw, we realized
that we'd have to re-engineer.
The first being applications
that relied on file storage.
So these were applications
that wrote to disk,
either the SanDisks on NetApps.
We realized, early on, that
there was a great opportunity
to move this to cloud
storage, which was more
suited for object storage.
Now, making this change
was a lot of work.
It involved a lot of change.
We practically rewrote
these components.
However, what we realized,
in rewriting them,
there was a lot of existing
complexity within these
applications-- for example,
to handle sharding between
multiple file end points or
to handle failures that only
happen within file systems--
we could remove.
And it actually greatly
simplified these applications.
Yes, we had to
introduce special code
to handle the fact that now
your writes have much higher
latency, because they're going
over HTTP, but, in the end,
we felt the
trade-off made sense.
The other two areas
where re-engineering
made complete sense
and was a no-brainer
was on the logging side
of components and data
engineering.
I'll go into that
specifics in a bit.
So if you look at all those
different components--
I said they were like almost
20 different components
and multiple subcomponents==
what I'm going to try to do
today, for you, is digest it all
and talk about these different
components or subcomponents
within these different levels.
So networking applies
for all the components
that we're talking about.
Let's start.
On a networking site,
on-prem, what we were running
were a lot of F5 load balancers.
How many of you all have F5
load balances in your data
center today?
OK.
As you guys probably know, those
things are great workhorses.
They're extremely reliable.
They are extremely flexible.
You're not going to have that
same level of flexibility
in the cloud.
And that was one
of the gaps that we
had to deal with, early on.
Within our on-prem data
center, the F5 LTMs
were used for both external
and internal load balancing.
They were also used for NAT.
So how did we migrate this
existing functionality to GCP?
We essentially ended up using
every type of load balancer
that's available in GCP.
We used the network load
balancer, the TCP Proxy Load
Balancer, HTTP load balancers,
and the internal load balancer.
And I'll go through
why we ended up
needing to use every single
load balancer in a bit.
The other aspect was NAT.
There was no immediate
NAT solution available.
Managed NAT is still not
available within GCP today,
at least I don't think it is.
Or maybe it's just coming out.
Two years ago, when we started,
it was not available yet.
So we ended up deploying
our own NAT solution.
We insured it's HA.
The good thing today
is, if you Google,
you will find several best
practice references on how
to set something like this up.
This is a solved problem.
At least we had to
roll our own back then.
And back then, we
weren't entirely sure
how to make sure that it was HA.
So we had to figure that out.
Other gotchas that
stuck out, when
we were doing the
networking piece, the first
was multi-cast.
Again, if you're on-prem
and run physical networking,
you're not going
to have problems
with having multi-cast.
Multi-cast is not available
on any cloud provider.
And we had components
that relied on multi-cast.
In particular, some of
our Java applications
use this grid caching
technology called Infinispan.
The good news there is
changing Infinispan,
from using multi-cast, to
using other type of drivers--
we ended up using TCP Ping--
is pretty straightforward.
So we had to make that change.
The other thing to be
aware of, especially
if you have a
large footprint, is
that there's a maximum cap
on the total amount of IPs
that you can have
within a network.
And this catches
big deployments off.
When we were doing this, we
had a maximum of 7,000 IPs.
And this led to a lot of
sleepless nights of us
trying to work things out.
The good news is, by the time
we actually went to production,
Google upgraded its network.
And now, today, they
support up of 15,000 IPs.
And our 6,000-odd infrastructure
footprint fit within it.
The other gotcha was
around load balancers.
And this is why we ended up
having multiple load balancers.
The first gotcha was
we had a service that
was serving an endpoint,
publicly, on port 5061.
The TCP load balancer supports
a specific list of ports.
There are about 12
ports that it support.
If you have existing
clients or services that
rely on these ports,
without changing it,
you're dead in the water.
You cannot serve from it.
So that's why we
had to replace it
with a network load
balancer, which
didn't have this limitation.
So now we have an NLB.
Secondly, we had services
with TLS endpoints
where the clients
were doing mutual TLS.
So we couldn't rely, again,
on HTTPS load balancers
where TLS was being terminated
on the load balancer.
We ended up solving this
by using TCP load balancers
and doing mutual TLS
on the instance itself.
Then we had a class
of applications,
with our bog standard
HTTPS endpoints,
and we could serve them through
the HTTP load balancers.
So these are some
of the limitations.
And again, you look
at what's out here.
You look at Kubernetes and
all this cool standard stuff.
But we don't have that
luxury when you're
moving existing infrastructure.
And finding these
type of problems early
and designing for
it is critical.
On the storage side, the
story was a bit more simpler.
The good news, the
summary or the upshot
was, for the most part, the
performance of Google's GCS
and PDSSD disks surpassed
what we were having
running in our data center.
We had NetApp appliances.
And we had SAN arrays
built off SSDs.
And both PDSSD and GCS was
a good fit and a replacement
for what was running there.
Now we get into the database
and caching side of things.
The first database that we
had to deal with were around--
we had a large
Oracle deployment.
Now, as some of you all might
know, if you've dug into this,
Oracle is not sanctioned
to run on GCP.
Neither did we want to
pay any Larry Ellison tax.
We think his yachts
are large enough.
So not only did we have to
plan to migrate the database,
we had to plan to
transform the database,
off Oracle, to Postgres
before actually rolling it
out or migrating it to GCP.
So we planned it in.
We got that done.
When it came to some of
those mySQL databases,
we just targeted CloudSQL as
CloudSQL was reasonably mature
by that point.
And not that many
of this database
was super critical for
production running of our app.
For Cassandra, a lot
of time was spent
trying to size the
instances that were going
to run the Cassandra nodes.
So figuring out, from a CPU,
RAM, we ended up using PDSSD.
Turned out, those were fast
enough for our use case.
We also spent a lot
of time working out
the operational aspects
of it, building playbooks,
understanding how we were
going to do rolling updates,
dealing with downed nodes.
All that had to be set up.
And we set up a special
team within our group
to handle that.
They got most of it set up
within two to three months.
But that was a big investment.
Redis and Memcached,
we started out
setting these up on our
own, doing something similar
to Cassandra.
But then we found
a partner, Aiven.
And they are pretty competent.
I would strongly
recommend them if you're
looking at trying to set
up something similar.
At that point, Memorystore
wasn't available.
We hope, going forward,
we can look at Memorystore
as a replacement for our third
party services from Aiven.
Net-net, we ended up with
about 400 Cassandra nodes,
a host of mySQL, Postgres,
and Memcached instances.
The next portion was monitoring.
And this is where
it got interesting.
What we had originally on-prem
was a large CA Wily deployment
capturing hundreds or
thousands of JMX metrics
from each instance.
All of this was then
graphed on Grafana
and alerting was
done through Nagios.
Now, when we first
looked at that,
our natural inclination
was, you know what?
Let's move all of
this to Stackdriver.
That makes sense.
It's provided in Google Cloud.
Why wouldn't we leverage it?
Turns out there was a
big mismatch, at least
at that point, two
years ago, with getting
JMX metrics, especially the
vast amount of JMX metrics
that our services were
using, into Stackdriver.
It was non-trivial.
We would end up needing
to write lots of scripts,
manually listing
out the JMX metrics.
It wouldn't scale.
The second aspect that we
found Stackdriver suffered with
was just around the sheer
size of our dashboarding.
The Stackdriver
dashboards back then--
I haven't looked at it lately,
so don't get upset with me--
but they just weren't
going to cut it.
They were underperforming.
They hung.
The amount of analytics that you
could do on it was very poor.
So we end up going with
Datadog, and that's
worked out quite well for us.
So what we have,
today, is a setup
that looks similar to this.
We export sensitive metrics that
don't come from the instance,
like GLB metrics, metrics
from your managed services,
from your networking, from your
software defined networking.
Those, we export from
Stackdriver to Datadog.
Apart from that, we run the
Datadog agent on our instances.
And that also pushes
metrics to Datadog.
Datadog then functions as a
system to collect our metrics,
as well for us to build
handle alerting on it.
These then become
available as dashboards,
which our ops team and
our developers use,
as well as for incident
management through OpsGenie.
It worked out, quite
well, for the most part.
Today, we have over 6,000
hosts, running in this manner,
and over 250,000 metrics
running on Datadog.
So it's quite scalable.
There are a couple of
gotchas worth considering.
Firstly, there was a lag between
capturing the Stackdriver
metrics to Datadog.
Now, I don't know
if they were just
trying to throw a Spanner
into that integration-- just
kidding.
But it was delayed.
And initially, it was unusable.
There was a six-minute
delay between something
happening on the
load balances and it
being available to Datadog.
We worked with Google and
Datadog to get that solved.
Today, the delay is
about a minute or less.
But there's still a delay.
And we continue to
work with them on it.
If you guys are looking
at a similar integration,
do push them along.
It will benefit all of us.
The other thing
worth considering
is that Datadog is not available
within the GCP infrastructure.
At least, when we
rolled it out, it
was hosted on AWS,
which meant that you're
going to have a fair
bit of egress going out
from your nodes,
especially if you have
a large enough
footprint like ours,
going to Datadog data
centers, which, I think,
now are AWS and
Europe and in US East.
However, the good news there
is the latencies introduced
by that wasn't too damaging.
For the most part, the
dashboards and the alerting
and the metrics are
all being captured
in reasonable amount of time.
And it's working OK for us.
The next aspect
was around logging.
And what we had
running on-prem was
we'd have instances running
a Kafka client that also
doubled up as a syslog agent.
So applications would
just log as though they're
logging to syslog.
It would then get picked up by
a Kafka client, which would then
push it to a Kafka broker.
And the Kafka broker
then had a bunch
of workers picking off
the logs and writing it
to a Hadoop file system.
This mostly worked.
But what it meant is
that, to query these logs,
users would need to
spin up Hadoop jobs
and basically do a
MapReduce to find logs.
This was a bit slow and painful.
So we wanted to re-engineer it.
We didn't want to just
have this coming along.
Secondly, also, especially if
you a replatforming on GCP,
there are tons of built
services, like Cloud Pub/Sub,
and Dataflow, that makes
sense to solve this problem.
And that's what
we ended up with.
So what we ended up with is
we ran the standard Fluentd
agent on the instances.
This Fluentd agent acts
as a local rsyslog daemon.
So again, you can have
those applications just
log as though they're
writing to syslog.
It then gets pushed to
Cloud Pub/Sub, which
then get picked up by Dataflow.
And then Dataflow
writes to two endpoints.
It writes to Elasticsearch
and is accessible to our team
through Kibana.
And it also writes
Avro files to GCS
and is accessible to
our teams from Zeppelin.
The use cases for Elasticsearch
and our Zeppelin, Kibana
is different.
Elasticsearch allows our users,
especially our operational team
or the developers
working on the services,
to access syslogs pretty quickly
and easily through some search
queries.
From a cost standpoint,
we try to keep
our Elasticsearch cluster
maintained at a fixed size.
We don't want it to
continuously grow.
So what that means is
that we age out logs.
So we keep up, up to
about 14-days retention
within our
Elasticsearch clusters.
But within GCS, we store those
logs, now, for perpetuity.
But what it means is that,
to access data from that,
it's a bit more tedious.
And we provide Zeppelin
as a front end for it.
And it mostly works.
It also serves as the input
for a lot of our data analytics
and data engineering jobs, which
is what I'll talk about now.
So on a big data standpoint,
as I mentioned earlier,
we had raw data in HadoopFS.
On-prem, we had a large
Hive-based data warehouse.
We were managing these data
engineering jobs using Oozie
and QlikView for dashboarding.
This entire stack
was re-platformed.
We replaced Oozie with
Airflow for job management.
We replaced all our
Hive data with Spark,
which would feed off GCS.
So the logs that we
had ingested earlier,
we also had event streaming
coming in through GCS.
And this would be picked
up by ETL jobs running
on Apache Spark.
This Apache Spark cluster
would also write back to GCS,
where necessary.
And for our data science
and data engineering work,
we would use Parquet files.
We would also sometimes,
primarily for business analysis
and for business
reporting, run ETL jobs
and write it
straight to BigQuery.
And then we'd have Tableau run
queries against our BigQuery
instance.
So this allowed us to--
in some cases, when you have
clear business reports that
are clearly defined and not
going to change too much,
we have ETL jobs
write to BigQuery
and make them queryable,
extremely quickly.
In cases where we want to
provide more ad hoc analytics,
we've provided that
through Zeppelin
running over our Parquet
files within GCS.
This, as well, has
worked quite well for us.
We migrated over 100 ETL jobs
that, today, run over 18,000
vCPUs.
We process 20 terabytes
of data a day.
And these jobs, on average, run
between one to two hours max.
In the past, when we
were running on-prem,
these jobs would take
sometimes up to two days.
So this has been a huge
improvement for the business.
And finally, at the
top of the stack
is our application service.
And for this, when we
looked at what was running,
initially, we saw a combination
of over 15 different type
of CPU, RAM, disk combinations.
We tried initially trying
to streamline this,
migrating what we had.
But what we found, in the end,
is that, at least for our use
cases, the configurations
that were running on-prem,
were not the configurations
that we ended up
running in the cloud.
In retrospect, it seems obvious.
Because we tried to autoscale
some of these instances, what
we could end up with was
we generally ended up
reducing the size
of the footprint
of these individual instances,
so that we could scale them
up and down easily.
So my suggestion,
here, the takeaway
here would be don't waste too
much time trying to do this,
especially if you're coming
from an on-prem environment.
Just get to the point that you
can test this, and figure it
out as you go along.
How you do that is what I'm
going to touch on a bit later.
So we've just finished
the whirlwind plan
of trying to figure out how
we're going to re-engineer,
what we're going to engineer,
how we're going to run that.
That, now again, took
us about two months-plus
sitting in windowless
meeting rooms,
working together
through partners,
like Pythian and CloudCover
and our engineering team,
and getting all that
bashed out, testing
some of the assumptions.
But now that we
had figured it out,
the next step was to actually
build the service up.
Now that we know where we want
to go, how do we get running?
The first thing that we did,
before actually coming up with
a plan was-- and this was
actually done quite early
in our transition plan--
is that we started
with some guiding
principles as to how we were
going to do traffic cutover.
And again, I think this
is a takeaway for teams.
You need to sit
with your business
and figure out what
is acceptable to them.
From our end, because we are
real-time messaging system,
with tens of millions of users,
it was decided that we cannot
afford to have any
downtime for our users.
I put an asterisk there, and
I'll come back to it in a bit.
But we didn't want to have
any downtime for our users.
We couldn't afford that.
What that meant, though,
is that, from a planning
standpoint, from a timeline
standpoint, we buffered things.
We stretched things out.
We ensured that
we had enough time
to do the engineering,
which is why
it took two years in the end.
There is definitely going
to be a trade-ff in terms
of how much downtime
you're willing to take,
and how much time the overall
transition is going to take.
That, you need to figure out
yourself, but do consider this.
The second thing that we
knew, from the get go,
is that we wanted to allow for
learning through the transition
process, through the
traffic cutover process.
Because, as I mentioned
earlier for the most part,
this was a team that
did not build or operate
this service before.
We knew that there were
lot of unknown unknowns.
And the only way to
figure these unknowns
was to actually
experience it when
we were running in production.
How did we achieve that?
We achieved that by ensuring
that the traffic cutover could
be done in an
incremental fashion.
And I'll touch on how we
achieved that in a bit.
The last thing is we wanted
to be resilient to mistakes.
We wanted to make sure that, if
we had a problem in the traffic
cutover, we didn't
have to incur downtime
until the problem was fixed.
We needed a way that we
could send traffic back
to our on-prem DC, and then
ensure that services could
continue to run while we figured
out how to actually fix it
in Google Cloud.
So that meant no big bangs.
We couldn't afford them.
The traffic cutover, itself, can
be broken down to four stages.
Firstly, we're setting
up joint networking.
Secondly, is getting the data
replicated, the appserver
deployment, and the client
traffic cutover itself.
Let's go through this.
One thing that's really nice
about Google Cloud, that we
leverage, was the
ability to set up
a dedicated interconnect
between our on-prem DC
and the data Centers in Asia.
Now, because Google has
a private interconnect--
they talk about it, it's
called their Premium network--
this ensured that
we could set up
these networks
between these DCs,
and they were low latency
and highly reliable.
We didn't have any outage,
any service impacting outage,
during the period.
Every now and then,
we'd have some spikes,
but they were mostly resolved.
But most importantly,
the latency
between our data centers
in Asia, back to Canada,
was between 200,
250 milliseconds.
This meant that we could do a
certain type of traffic cutover
strategies that not having this
type of latency would afford.
So, for example, if the
latencies were a lot higher,
some of the database replication
techniques wouldn't work.
I'll touch on that a bit.
So because a large
footprint of our data
was stored in Cassandra, that
got us replication for free.
Cassandra, as some of
you guys probably know,
has native replication
built into it.
So that was pretty
straightforward.
We spun up our
Cassandra nodes, let
the replication run through,
and we had our data in GCP.
When it came to Postgres, we set
up master-slave replications.
Alvaro is here.
He worked with us on it.
And what we had
to do, in the end,
to actually get the users
onto the new master,
was to actually do
a master promotion.
Now, this is the one time that
we had to take some downtime.
When we made the
master promotion,
we then have the application
service point to the new master
and proxy request back from
the old application service.
So there was some
minimal downtime,
of about 5 to 10 minutes,
while this process was ongoing.
This didn't impact any of
our key services, though.
Messages continued to work.
People could chat
with each other.
And therefore, it was
seen as acceptable.
When it came to caches, we
modified our application
to be able to do dual writes.
So any application that
would use Memcached or Redis,
we introduced the ability to
define more than one cluster.
It would write to both
clusters, one cluster operating
in GCP, the other on-prem.
And then, when we
finally cutover,
we would both read and
write from the next cluster.
So we have the
networking set up.
We've got the data migrated.
The next step was actually
rolling out the appservers.
Now, if you remember
from the start,
I mentioned there were
many, many appservers,
many, many services.
So the first step
was to really map out
all the dependencies, with
the application servers,
and pick one application
server with the least
amount of dependencies.
We then would take the
deployment of that application
server till the end.
What I mean by
"till the end" is we
would have production traffic
working on that one application
server, that one service,
before moving to the next.
This is almost like canarying
your traffic cutover.
It allowed us to ensure
that any type of mistakes
that we might have made
with our first service,
we did not repeat for
subsequent services
that we were cutting over.
And I think this was
very useful for us.
So when we moved the
service over to GCP,
if there were any requests that
were dependent on services that
weren't in GCP yet,
because we are cutting
one service at a
time, again, we would
be able to leverage our
GCP direct interconnect
to just proxy this request back
to our on-prem data center.
If we didn't have
that low latency link,
a lot of these type of
migration techniques
wouldn't be possible.
Once we had the single,
individual appserver running
in GCP, we would then cut server
to server traffic to it first.
And again, that also would
be cut incrementally.
We'd have 10% of the
fleet make the requests,
and then slowly bump
it up more as we
had more assurance that the
service was running fine.
We then moved to the
client traffic cutover.
How did we do this
incrementally?
The first step required
instrumenting the client
to be able to receive service
endpoints from a third party,
so basically push the
service endpoints to it.
The way we achieved
this was, obviously,
we had to push out a new
version of a client that
supported this capability.
But we also leveraged
Firebase Remote Config,
as the back end service, to push
these values or these service
endpoints to the client.
We could have built our
own service to do this,
but the benefit of using
Firebase Remote Config
was that it already has internal
capabilities around client
targeting that proved
to be very useful,
and it also allows you to
roll values of key updates
incrementally.
So we could say 1% of the
entire client population
has this new service endpoint,
see how the service performs,
and then slowly ramp this up.
When we got to 100%, we'd
then move to the next service.
So essentially,
that's what it was.
We did service by
service, piece by piece.
We take the learnings and
then apply to the next one.
You repeat it 20
times, and you fully
cutover without
your users knowing.
And that's it.
That's how we migrated the
entire BBM service to GCP.
I think there are a
couple of key learnings
that we discovered
as we went along.
Firstly, is there are
definitely going to be gotchas.
Unless you are deploying a
Cloud-native service that
was already designed
for the Cloud,
there are gotchas
hiding somewhere.
And you need to dig them out.
If you haven't
found them yet, it's
probably because you
haven't looked hard enough.
Get alignment from the business
in terms of what impact
they're willing to take
as part of the transition.
This will really define how
much effort and time and money
you're going to need to
invest into your transition.
The third aspect is-- and this
is something that we totally
missed when we
were starting out--
the communications, between
the different teams involved
in the transition,
is going to be
your single, toughest,
non-technical problem.
We were not prepared for this.
This communication can
be between any group.
It could be between your
partners, yourself, and Google
Cloud technical team.
Or in our case, for example,
it was that, and also
the combinatorial
impact of having teams
spread across Canada,
Singapore, and Jakarta.
You multiply all
this, and you've
got a very n square
problem on your hand.
Lastly, I'd say--
and this really
worked well for us-- is
bake-in the ability to fail.
You're going to be
making mistakes.
That's the only way you're going
to get something complex right.
If you bake it in
from the start,
you can recover,
learn, and move on.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]